dad calls me
and
we have a small discussion about how
that my covet was I didn't remind him
that it was my birthday because I wanted
to see if he remembered
and he didn't
Mr wives star Gabriel Brown in tears
after his dad Cody forgets his birthday
I'm working with my family I I really
enjoy what I do
but I'm a flawed individual and it's not
fun to see that the 21 year old's
emotional breakdown happened because
Cody Robin and their kids contracted
covet 19. God I can't believe it man
covid-19 after 20 months of avoiding
it's crazy I'm sitting here just going
through the motions here and because
Gabriel whom Cody shares with Janelle
had it previous
sides to call for some advice despite
their already strained relationship
October rolls around specifically
October 11th my birthday
um and dad calls me
and
we have a small discussion about how
that my covet was
I shouldn't have done this but I did
anyway
um
I didn't remind him that it was my
birthday because I wanted to see if he
remembered
and he didn't
and that's when Gabe couldn't hold back
his tears
it was a lot worse than just a phone
call for me a couple hours after that
he tried to call me back
tell me happy birthday and make up for
it and that's the last time I ever
talked to my dad
it's no secret their father and son
relationship is Rocky last season the
two butted heads about Cody's strict
coveted rules during the pandemic along
with Janelle he acts like I'm not doing
anything
I wear a mask I social distance I
sanitize my hands I do all the things
that the CDC says to do but because I
don't follow all of his Ten Commandments
his rules I'm not following any rules
apparently and when it came to the
holidays Cody didn't want Gabriel and
their other son Garrison to be part of
the family's Thanksgiving plans you guys
decide what you do because I'm not going
to tell this family how they do it I am
going to lead the way that I think is
the right way we've had some
misunderstandings because of kobid
marriage to put a little little more
pressure on a relationship and um so
it's like hey if you're not over it's
because you don't like me uh no if I'm
not over it's because you didn't follow
kobit protocols and this season
Janelle's still facing the same issue
our Thanksgiving last year was
um separate this year there's such a big
divide between Cody and my boys
that I don't know what we want to do for
Thanksgiving I'm not going to have them
come to my house for Thanksgiving if
they've got animosity towards me
or somebody that is connected to me
[Music]